This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.  This
text, document, or file is not
to be distributed or used in any
way that may violate copyright
law.
***
I was just asking my friends how
you get your classrooms quiet,
but I don't even have to use my
new trick. Thank you. We are so
happy that you are here at the
library of congress this
morning,
and really excited to both
welcome you
and introduce you to a terrific
new author that you might have
heard of
before
. I direct a new office of
learning and
innovation here at the lie BRAGS
library. We have another group
coming in, and I
will let them trickle in
.
First thing I want to do is
recognize all of the groups in
the audience with us today. When
I say the name of your school, I
want you to get a big smile on
your face. And then when I've
read all of the
school names, that's when I want
you all to clap. So, when I read
your school name, you're going
to smile. When I finish, you're
going to clap. Okay? All right.
So today we are very happy to be
welcome
ing students and parents and
chaperons
from Ledlow, trues dale
education campus, from the
inspired teaching demonstration
public charter school,
from Dorothy height elementary,
from
Tyler elementary, from
Kimableble elementary, and from
Brant elementary school. Now we
can cheer.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
» LEE ANN POTTER: That was
perfect!
We
also-- thank you. Hey I I see
some of you doing this.
And that seems to work. Awesome.
Thank you guys.
I'm also excited to let you know
that in addition to all of the
students that are with us at the
library today, we have people
all over the world watching
this
program on YouTube and on the
library's website and on the
library's Facebook page, because
we're live streaming it. And
that camera right there, if you
want to wave to it, you can wave
to people all over the whole
wide world!
I think they liked that. Thank
you. Now on with our show, so
last December, here at the
library of congress, we had
a special program celebrating a
book.
ApproximateThe book we were sell
BRALTcelebrating was publiced in
lished in 1936, and was turned
into a movie.
You either read the book, "the
story of Ferdinand" or you saw
the movie.
Well, in the movie
--
in "Ferdinand" the movie, the
voice of
Ferdinand was John see Cena, and
he came here to the library and
read the original book to a
group of students in this very
auditorium. Today we are very
happy that he is back with us
again, and once again,
inspiration is part of our
program. Last December, when we
introduced John, we described
him as an actor and as a
wrestling superstar, and those
descriptions certainly still
apply.
But today, we get to add author
to his description.
He has written a new book
entitled "Elbow Grease".
It was illustrated by Howard
McWilliam, and published by
Random House. And a copy of this
is now in the
library of congress's
collection, so it is part of the
largest library in the world.
John is here not only to read
"Elbow
Grease", but also one written
and
illustrated by Richard Scary,
which inspired him. John will
talk with us a bit and answer
questions that I know a few of
you have.
So, please join me in welcoming
16-time
world champion wrestler, star of
block
buster movies, record-setting
make-a-wish granter, reader, fan
of Richard Scary books, and
published author, John Cena!
[ Applause ]
» JOHN CENA: How is everybody
doing this morning. Is it okay
if I sit? No? Yes? Sit?
I can't -- yes or no?
» AUDIENCE: Yes!!!
» JOHN CENA: I heard everybody
singing before I came out here.
You all have a wonderful voice.
Collectively it sounded
wonderful. Singing is fun,
right? I couldn't quite
understand you. Singing is fun,
right? Singing is great, and
drawing is great,
and maybe watching shows are
great, and telling stories is
great, because it's all
creative. And all of us, no
matter where we come from, no
matter what we look like, all of
us have inside of us this
wonderful thing called
imagination. And when you get to
sing or you watch
something that stimulates your
imagination, it's fun. And to
me, what also stimulates my
imagination is books. Books more
than anything else, because in
the pages, you can kind of
determine what the characters
are like, maybe develop a voice
for somebody or a personality
for a character.
So, books, certainly, are one of
my favorite ways to be
imaginative. And I, of course,
have a list of favorite books.
But I wanted to ask you guys
some questions.
What makes iss a book a
favorite?
I know for me, but what about
you guys? What are some of the
things that you look for in a
book that makes it a
favorite
? We have a few answers out
there. This is very interesting
to me, because I know all of our
answers are going to be
different.
Initial reports are coming in.
The question: Things that make a
book a favorite. Mystery. A good
old-fashioned guessing game of
what's really going on. Mystery
is good. Imagination.
Imagination.
That's also one of my faves as
well. Inspiration. A very good
and powerful word, and hopefully
we have some inspiration here
today. What else have we got?
Im
aginative. Seems to be a good
amount of imagination in the
room. It's going to be a
wonderful morning. Pictures.
Pictures are also a key part of
the book, because it can help
you imagine the world that the
storyteller is trying to create.
These are all great answers, by
the way. Thank you so much. And
so many people want to
contribute.
This is great! It takes you
somewhere. That's the wonderful
thing about books. It takes us
to someplace special. They're
very powerful. Yes, they are
very powerful. The stories that
they tell are very powerful.
Cool words
like Elbow Grease! And having a
lot of books. That's extremely
important, because the more
books you have, the more stories
you can be involved in. Fiction.
Fiction is another great answer.
We have one in the front.
We have one coming up on the
front. Colorful. That goes along
with amazing pictures, being
colorful and vibrant.  And
traveling.
Traveling is something that can
take stories wherever you want
to be around the world or
beyond.
So, those are all -- and
non-fiction! The opposite of
fiction. We'll include
everything, which is great.
We're at the library of
congress.  We should give
everything their due.
So, those are all great
answers. And I want to thank you
for you sharing with me what
makes your books favorites. I
wanted to share with you a book
that
was my absolute favorite when I
was a little kid. I grew up in a
small town. It was nothing like
DC.
You couldn't see fancy buildings
and people walking the streets
and tons of
cars and trucks and things that
go. You had farmland, and I was
lucky to maybe get a glimpse at
a rusted old tractor, and my
next-door neighbor was miles and
miles away.
So, when my mom read me this
story,
"Cars and Trucks and Things that
Go," I didn't hang on every
word, because there's a lot of
them in there for a children's
book. It's a long book. But what
I loved, as some of you
pointed out, I loved the
pictures, because it brought me
to a world where I could see
these amazing machines that I
had only heard about.
But if you open the book -- I'll
just even flip to page 9.
There's a pickle truck. A giant
pickle truck.
There's also a dragster and a
crocodile
car and a sailboat, and there's
a tow truck and what looks like
a sports car
and what looks like an antique
sports car and a milk truck. And
this is only one page. I saw
this as a kid, and I was like
man, the pickle truck is bigger
than everything else! It's huge!
If you turn to page -- oooh.
This is a good one. So, page 15.
I always loved construction.
I loved bulldozers because they
could
smash and cranes baudss because
they could lift things and big
trucks because
they could  carry and tow
things.
On one page you have a crane, a
bulldozer, and a real small
minivan, which is a mouse van,
you have a pumpkin car, a
rainbow bus, and a bunch of
really cool stuff. And, oh, I
think this was my favorite page
of the whole book, because I
loved making a mess as a little
kid, and I loved big trucks.
And you could see all sorts of
dump trucks, what they carry.
And they're all making a mess.
You have trucks that carry coal,
trucks that carry rocks, carry
dirt, tomatoes, oranges, and
trucks that carry sand, and
they're all making a mess. And
as a kid, I loved this.
And it's just an example of your
answers to these questions about
what makes a book your favorite.
If you turn to even page 35, you
again see dump trucks, but
instead of making a mess this
time, they're building a road.
So, they're doing something
productive and they're making a
road to help make a city. And
then I got to thinking as a kid,
who's going to live in that
city? What's the city going to
look like?
Man, it must be a crazy far-away
place!
And on page 45, I don't know if
you know this about me, but I
like to drive pretty fast. Like,
the speed limit... almost. But
I've always liked fast cars, and
this is a whole page devoted to
cars that go fast.
And as a kid, I just couldn't
believe that all of this
material was in one book.
And guys, this is only five
pages of this massive, massive
book. And once again, I loved
when my mom used to read me this
story, but she used to read it
and the words almost felt
like music, because I was so
lost in the pictures.
And that's the great thing about
books, especially from some of
the answers we've heard. If
they're colorful, if they're
vibrant, if they have a great
story, if they have a little bit
of mystery, if they have
wonderful pictures, it can
allow us to use that powerful
thing called imagination that
allows us to create fantastic
and wonderful things.
So, I want to ask you a few
question s before we get into
this little guy, who I admire.
How many of you, like me, like
cars? Okay. There's a few. How
many like trucks? How many like
cars and trucks?
Okay.
How many of you have brothers?
How many of you -- okay. All
right. All right. Energetic
subject. Maybe you've got a big
brother or a little brother. How
many of you have sisters? Oh,
okay. All right. How many of you
have brothers and sisters?
Raise your hand if you have a
brother, a sister, or a cousin.
Okay.
This one we did pretty good
with. And that's a very
important question, because it
has to do with a story we're
about to read.
I wanted to ask if you have a
brother, a sister, or a cousin,
because you know what it's like
to be close to someone who is
family. Sometimes you get along.
Sometimes maybe you have a
disagreement and you don't get
along. But at the end of the
day, because you're family and
you spend time together, you
develop love and bond with one
another. And that's kind of what
led me to want to write "Elbow
Grease", because as
you'll soon find out, Elbow
Grease lived in a wonderful
world of imagination, but he's a
little bit different from his
brothers and sometimes his
brothers don't understand and
make fun of him for it. But
Elbow Grease doesn't care
because he is proud of who he
is. It was because of my family
that I wanted to write this
story that I'm going to share
with you today.
Would it be okay right now if I
were to share that story with
you?
[ Audience answers ].
I must apologize. I'm not as
young as I used to be and they
say that hear something the
first thing to go. I didn't hear
your answer. Would it be okay if
I share this story
with you? Was that a yes? I've
got to ask one more time. Would
it be okay?
[ Audience yelling yes! ]
All right.
Well, without further ado, the
moment we've all been waiting
for, the
wonderful story of "Elbow
Grease".
Here is our cast of characters.
There is Elbow Grease. He he,
that tickles.  Flash. Come on,
bud, story's starting.  Pinball,
technically at this point, the
story has already started. And
Tank, what story? And of course,
Crash! Last one there's a hunk
of junk!
"Elbow Grease".
Hey, that's me!
All right. Elbow Grease was
the smallest truck in
the demolition derby, but he
never that bother him.
Why should I?
His brother, Tank, was tougher.
His brother Flash was faster.
His brother Pinball was smarter.
His brother Crash was braver!
Okay. We get the point.
But what Elbow Grease had was
gumption! You got that right,
buster!
He always tried his best,
and he never gave up. Ouch! Waaa
! Oops! Yowww!
At night, Mel the mechanic
plugged
in Elbow Grease to charge while
the other trucks slept outside.
Sometimes his brothers teased
him for being different. -he's
got a plug. He's stuck to the
wall.
He's got alith on-ion battery
which requires an external power
source for daily recharging.
Huh huh huh. He's got a
plug.
Elbow Grease didn't get
upset. He was glad to be inside.
Especially during the
rainstorms.
Yeah, have fun in the rain, you
jalopies!
Then one might Mel brought home
a
post
er and Elbow Grease said, "Some
day, I'm going to be on a
poster." His brothers laughed.
YYou're too slow. You're too
small.
Your technique and experience
are insufficient to compete at a
professional level. You're
too... uhhh...
Don't hurt yourself, thank.
That made Elbow Grease mad.
So mad that he zoomed off to the
Grand
Prix by HIMSS himself to prove
his brothers wrong.
I'll show those JAjalopieses
what I can do. By the morning,
Elbow Grease was exhausted. He
had been driving all night
without a charge. But when he
arrived at the Grand Prix,
he felt his circuits surge with
excitement, and
he quitely pulled on to the
track and snuck behind the other
trucks. On your mark, get set,
go!
The other trucks were bigger.
The other trucks were faster.
The other trucks had more
experience and better technique.
But Elbow Grease wouldn't quit.
Never give up!
He fell behind.
But he kept on trucking
. Off. He got bashed and
smashed, and even caught fire a
little bit.
But still, he kept on going
. Ow-y kazow-y!!!
Half way through the race,
it started pouring rain.
Thunder rumbled, lightning
Flashed, and
all of the Sunday sudden, Elbow
Grease's engine shut down. His
battery was completely dead. Oh
rust buckets. Elbow Grease was
stuck, and for the
first time, he wondered if his
brothers were right.
And he started to cry.
I'm not c-c-crying.
I'm just cold and tired and kind
of
scared of the lightning
. CRACK-A-LACK-A!
BOOM-SHOCK-A-LOCK-A!!!!
The lightning jumped his battery
back to life. Elbow Grease
barely had enough charge to keep
going, but he didn't give up and
he didn't give in. No matter
what, he would finish this
race, even if he came in last.
Mel and Elbow Grease's brothers
arrived just in time to see him
rattle across the finish line
and collapse in a heap. And the
winner's celebration was
already over
. Look, Bo, most of the trucks
couldn't even make it to the
finish line.
And just then, the winner of the
race rolled by.
Well, shift my gears and call me
sally, this kid's got gumption.
You boys could learn a lot from
him.
Crash was shocked. Big? Flash
was stunned. Wheels?
Pinball was intrigued. McGeel?
Tank? Tank was confused.
Who?
Mel NUknew that Big Wheels
McGeel was right. If you only
stick with what you're good at,
you'll never learn anything.
So, the next time your problem
seems
too big or too hard, just
remember, a
little elbowElbow Grease goeses
a long a long, long way. The
end.
[ Applause ]
First thing's first, I want to
say thank you very much for
allowing me to share something
that's part of my imagination
with you. And secondly, I hope
maybe we can all use our
imagination today to maybe see
the world of Elbow Grease and
maybe a wonderful message at the
same time. But lastly, and most
important, I know
you guys and gals have
questions. And I would like to
answer those questions now. So,
I made a little bit of extra
time, because I saw how many
questions and answers we had at
the beginning, and I want to
make sure if you have a
question, I'll do my best to
answer it. This is the most
important part. If you have
questions, I have answers. Let's
go.
» LEE ANN POTTER: We're going
to start with those questions,
and if we
have additional time, we'll move
on to some other questions. So,
my colleague who has the
microphones floating around, I
think
Sasha's got one back here
, and I think what we'll have is
two microphones on each side of
the room.
And if you have a question that
is on one of the Flash cards, if
you could hold it up so that my
friends in the audience could
see you, they're going to walk
up to you, and they're going to
ask you to say your name, and
then ask your question. Okay?
All right! Sasha, we'll start
with who you've got here.
» JOHN CENA: What's the first
question?
» My name is Semetrus, and the
question is what's your second
favorite book?
» JOHN CENA: What's... say
again?
» What's your second-favorite
book?
» JOHN CENA: Second favorite
book,
beside s ss "Elbow Grease" and
"Cars and
Trucks and Things that Go," I
love Dr.
Seuss, so maybe green eggsGreen
Eggs and Ham. Great question.
» Do you have someone
"Green Eggs and Ham."  Great
question.
» Do you have someone?
» Hi. My name is Austin, and
I would like to ask you, do you
still like cars and trucks? And
why?
» JOHN CENA: Do I still like
cars and trucks? You know, I'm a
little bit older now, so...
YES! I absolutely do. I do!
Because cars and the way they're
designed is someone's
imagination come to life. If
it's a sports car or if it's a
truck, just the way it looks and
the way it drives is someone's
idea, and I like
that
.
» LEE ANN POTTER: I think we
have another question over here,
Sasha.
» JOHN CENA: You have a lot of
excitement.
» My question is, are you going
to write another book?
» JOHN CENA: Hmmm. Am I going to
write another book?
Honestly, that depends on you
folks.
Would you like me to write
another book?
[ Cheers and Applause ]
» Thank you.
» JOHN CENA: So you like
actually liked the story that
you heard?
[ Cheers and Applause ]
And if given the chance, you
would want me to write another
book?
[ Cheers and Applause ]
Thank you very much for saying
that. I think this will not be
the last of the books. Thank
you.
» Do you like wrestling?
» JOHN CENA: There was a
question
from the front right-hand
corner. The question was --
» Do you like wrestling STH.
» JOHN CENA:e inging?
» JOHN CENA: Do I like
wrestling? I am proud enough to
say that I have
won the world championship 16
times!
[ Cheers and Applause ]
I think some people are excited
about that. Yes. I absolutely
love WWE. That is a great
question. Thank you for asking.
» LEE ANN POTTER: Mia, do you
have a
question back there?
Mia
?
» JOHN CENA: We have an
important question coming in.
Let's listen up to the question.
Please.
» My name is I
gnatious, and my question is,
how many
books did you read in second
grade?
» JOHN CENA: How many books did
I read in second grade? I was
fortunate enough to have a
second
grade teacher whose fair thing
was favorite thing was book
reports.
In second grade, I didn't think
it was such a good idea. I
thought these crumby book
reports. I got to write down all
of this stuff about the books I
read. But looking back, I read a
lot of books.
I would say in second grade, at
the very least, because I'm just
going to
ballpark it, at the very least,
10 books, and at the very most,
probably 15 books, but without
that teacher, I probably only
would have read one or two.
So, I'm very happy for my
teachers.
An excellent question right
here.
» My name is Avery, and my
question is how did you pick the
title for "Elbow Grease"?
» JOHN CENA: Okay. Okay.
Do you folks know what elbow
grease means? No?
This is a Firth first time,
because
usually it's an overwhelming
yes! That's okay. There's a lot
of you out there that
don't know what the word "elbow
grease" means, which is why I
chose it. I want you to be so
entertained by the
story that you ask someone what
does elbow grease mean? I wrote
the book.
Elbow grease means hard work,
and
that's why Elbow Grease's
special talent is gumption, and
that is why he never gave up.
Not only did you hear a good
story, but you also learned
something; you know
that elbow grease means hard
work.
» My name is Constance
. How strong are you?
» How strong are you?
» JOHN CENA: Ooo... I am strong
enough to keep myself out of
trouble.
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
I don't get myself into trouble.
Another. That is a good
question.
We have one more way up in the
back.
» What is your favorite thing
that says vroom? Like a car?
» JOHN CENA: Oooh!
What is my favorite thing that
says Vroom? Anything that sounds
like it goes fast. Because
you've heard some cars, and I'm
a huge fan of the electric cars,
but I
wish they could come with, like,
speakers in them, so when you
plug your
phone in, it's like vrooooom,
vrooom! It's just because I grew
up with it. But I'm learning to
like no noise. Do we have more?
Of course we have more. Where is
our next question coming from?
» Right over here.
» My name is --
» JOHN CENA: We have one.
» My name is Juaro, and my
question is, what book are you
reading now? My question is,
what book are you reading now?
» JOHN CENA: Okay. That's a
great question.
So, besides reading "Elbow
Grease", I'm reading a wonderful
story called the
storied life of AJ Fickry, it's
about a bookstore owner and his
journey of life through books.
And it's really, really good,
but maybe for a few years down
the road.
Yes, right here.
» My name is Charlie, and how
long did it take you to write
"Elbow Grease"?
» JOHN CENA: Oh, so, I'll
answer the question with a
question.
How long do you guys think it
took to write "Elbow Grease"?
30 minutes? Five minutes?
Ten minutes? Six minutes? Two
minutes? I see a lot of twos.
Would you like to know?
Would you like to know how long
it took? Okay. Okay.
Okay
. It took
me three years. Three whole
years to write "Elbow Grease".
Now it seems pretty simple, but
it's not simple. It's really
hard. And that's why I really
wanted to tell the story,
because even though Elbow
Grease never gives up, there
were times in those three years
that I could have been like man,
this is too tough. Or it's never
going to work. And I never gave
up, and I have a wonderful story
to show for it, and I'm able to
sit here and share it with you.
So, it took a long time, and it
was tough. It wasn't easy. Just
remember that. Sometimes the
things you enjoy, they're not
easy. They're tough, and they
take a while. But keep at it and
never give up.
Do we have another question?
» My name is Julien, and my
question is what is your
favorite color and your favorite
ice cream flavor?
» JOHN CENA: I'll only allow
those two questions in one
question, because they're very
good questions.
Favorite color right now is
blue,
because that's the color of
Elbow Grease.
Favorite ice cream flavor is
chocolate
chip cookie dough with
M&Ms, and with hot fudge and
sprinkles. I'm sure we have
more. I'm sure we have more
questions. We have one right
here!
» My name is Livie, and what do
you eat for breakfast?
» JOHN CENA: What do I eat for
breakfast?
I wish it was chocolate chip
cookie dough ice cream. It's
not.
I usually have a bowl of serial
seral
of cereal, some eggs, and a big
glass of water.
All right. Do we have more
questions? Do we have time?
» LEE ANN POTTER: I think we
have about five more minutes.
» JOHN CENA: Yeah. Let's get
more questions out there.
» LEE ANN POTTER: All right!
» My name is Domonic --
» JOHN CENA: Okay. We have a
question.
» Are you still a --
» JOHN CENA: Now Jonathan, I
thank you very much for your
question, but I think you're a
little bit confused.
You see
, Bre is married to Daniel
Grimes, so if
I answered your question yes,
that would get me in a whole lot
of trouble. So, the answer is
no.
Do we have another question
? We have a question. We have a
question. We have a question.
» My name is Domonic, and do you
still wrestle?
» JOHN CENA: Do I still --
Have I --
How could you ask such a
question?
I was just in Australia on
October 6 in a WWE ring. And the
next time in case you're
wondering, I'll be in a WWE ring
is
November 2 in a giant TOURNL
tournament
to see what who's the best in
the world. So, yes, I'm still in
WWE. So, next? We have one. We
have a question.
» Have you beat The Rock before?
» JOHN CENA: Have I beat The
Rock before? Does anyone know
the answer to that question?
Have I beat The Rock before?
One more time, have I beat the
rockThe Rock before? I have.
But, he's also beat me.
So I've won, and I've lost.
» LEE ANN POTTER: I think we
have time for two more
questions.
» JOHN CENA: You are doing a
wonderful job. There's a lot of
questions out there, a lot of
excitement.
Do we have a question?
» LEE ANN POTTER: Okay. I
think we have one over here.
» JOHN CENA: We have one
right here.
» My name is Micah, and my
question
is, why did you become an
author?
» JOHN CENA: Oooo. That's a
great question.
Because I wanted to encourage
young people to read. That's why
I didn't write an adult book. I
wanted to become a children's
author, because I know a lot of
children watch WWE, and a lot of
children like to see
me perform, so I wanted to give
a chance for young people to
become readers.
» LEE ANN POTTER: And one
more, and that'll do it.
» JOHN CENA: One more
question. The final question. It
could be about ice cream...
» Hi, what is your favorite
t-shirt?
I mean your favorite shirt?
» JOHN CENA: What's my
favorite shirt?
Well, I can't tell you that it's
what I have on, because I just
dressed up for you guys and I
wanted to look nice.
But, there's a picture of it
right here.
[ Laughter ]
I made sure that was my one
demand when we did this whole
giant photo shoot.
I said you better have my
favorite
T-shirt there, and lo and
behold, my favorite t-shirt was
there. White and comfortable.
» Thank you.
» JOHN CENA: You're very
welcome. And wait a second.
Before we wrap up the morning, I
wanted to say thank you. Thank
all of you. Because I know
sometimes it's difficult to sit
in a place and listen to people
talk. You guys have been a
wonderful audience. I want to
thank you. I want to thank your
parents. I want to thank your
teachers. I hope we had some fun
today. Did you guys have some
fun? This is probably the last
time today you'll be able to
scream really loud, so give me
all you got! Did you have some
fun today?
[ Cheers and Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause
continue...
]
Pretty good. Pretty good.
So there the most important
thing I wanted to tell you guys
is -- I just wanted to make
sure. That was very impressive.
I want to thank everybody for
being here today. I want to
thank you for giving me so much
energy to get through the rest
of my day. I hope you have a
wonderful day, and I hope you
enjoyed the story. Thank you
very much.
» LEE ANN POTTER: And John, the
library thanks you, too. Thank
you.